hi i'm kristen wiig and i play vicki st
elmo hi my name is will forte and i play
the character of mcgruber in the
upcoming television series magruber we
are here to take the co-star test
check off each of the details you're
absolutely sure this is all capitalized
and in bold absolutely sure you know
about your co-star oh i hope it's a time
i know i hope it is too let's try to
talk me on this
no i'm not i'm terrible with like my
memory so bad their birthday kristen wig
i do not know your birthday i feel like
i know your month i'm not even sure i
know your month yeah wait wait we both
celebrated our birthdays yeah yeah on
the shoot but we don't know each other
we're not absolutely sure so we can't
check that we're not absolutely sure are
you july
june
i'm june i know you knew that
may august
we didn't start shooting
all new it's the only one left you know
so neither one of us we don't get this
one i was messing with you august was i
knew that
okay so i'm up i got one and you have
zero no their dressing room must have
we spent a lot of time in
mainly in your dressing room because the
dressing room was awesome wait but to be
clear we had the same dressing room the
same trailer we have the same trailer
she outfits she goes and makes it super
comfortable i bought blankets for the
couch i bought some candles mine just
got the dirty
rug you got the dirty rug that's what
you wanted you wanted the dirty room
actually it was it was fine but but you
go into hers and you're just transported
you're making it sound like i
redecorated the whole thing so i would
have said your your must-have it was
just like the really soft poofy rug
which was fantastic it was nice to sit
on your dressing room must have is
toilet paper
spoiler we could we could hear each
other in the bathroom
our bathrooms were
you know if i went
i'd be like well some squeaking over
there i could hear the toilet seat like
sometimes going up and down and i knew
when you were going
you know if i heard her going in there
i'd i'd you know try to respect her
her bathroom privacy and and you know
make loud noises to cover
what you know it couldn't cover the
sound of those tremendous booming firsts
but
but you know i did my best
okay first time we met i know this one
we've talked about though i yeah i am
yeah we both know this one ready let's
say it on the count of three okay one
two three
chili cook-off oh
no you're right it was your birthday i
really thought we were gonna get that
one it was the bowling alley right
your birthday yeah no it was a bar in
venice do you think it was your birthday
your favorite movie of all time i know
that you're
a huge fan of your own work so
bridesmaids
barbie star go to vista del mar and
they're great but like you just can't
stop talking about them yeah you know i
was in this and that's my favorite i
just say that to people on the street
yeah i think your favorite those aren't
my favorite movies by the way no they're
not i wonder if we have the same
favorite comedy i definitely have a
favorite comedy airplane no but that's
so good why is that not my favorite
movie caddyshack nope oh my god am i
just going to sit here and eat coffee
you know what i'm just going to tell you
yeah the jerk
oh yeah of course i'm going to guess for
you
it's uh xanadu favorite comedy shawshank
redemption no you're a k-9 she's a
citizen kane
their town i know yours northern
california but i don't know exactly
which oh geez but you don't remember
mine it's okay i don't even remember i
mean i know you're the united united
states of america
um that's close
you're not florida are you no
are you like
northeast
upstate new york oh yeah so it is
northeast so i nailed it your favorite
character that you portrayed in a
different project i'm gonna say the
character you played in nebraska yeah
and for you i'm gonna guess bourbon star
you're right their middle name i know
your middle name is oroville carol yep
their favorite scene you shot together
on this project that's really hard i
kind of have a favorite what do you
think my favorite is i think your
favorite is
it's the dramatic scene outside yeah
because that was mine too yeah oh wait i
shouldn't tell you that well i was gonna
i was gonna guess that for you just
because very few times in mcgruber yeah
is there is it grounded in this type of
way and it was it was really nice and
and you know she's just such a an
impressive dramatic actor that it's fun
so are you try to see if you can fricken
with the best their favorite snack at
crafty the main thing that i definitely
remember you loving uh
i don't know if i get a point from this
okay were those popcorns that had
little bits of candy in them like
chocolate we both discovered those m m's
not the peanut m ms you didn't like the
peanut m ms very specific even though
you're wrong i'm giving you a point
because you're so specific no i'm just
kidding no you're right i did okay that
was a late in the game but that was a
phase and like that was a phase i think
we both love a chip
chip do you think i would probably
i
think maybe like
a sun chip yes
yes you definitely get a point okay
their go-to activity between filming
scenes you really like making videos i
you'd love but she's so good at putting
together
videos just fun videos she's great with
sound effects afterwards it's it's so
delightful but i remember particularly
you were trying to put one together for
somebody who had made some bejeweled
crocs for you the crocs were a character
and the crocs were like they were upset
because they didn't have any jewels and
i would call the crocs and they wouldn't
answer and then they'd be in the
dressing room with like a cigarette and
like a bottle they were like really
depressed and like a bottle of booze but
i was going to say the same with you
like we did like to make videos together
so that's kind of like i would say we're
still at a tie thank you for watching us
if you're still watching yammer on for a
while about each other and please uh go
watch the mcgruber series on peacock
thank you thank you carol orville
you